we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine to david p here's a
voicemail i received yeah i just gotta
tell you guys I'm can be my buddies
asura watching TV here and this happen
to flip on your station yeah and we're
trying to determine if it is actually a
comedy or not this is the most ludicrous
ridiculous I have ever heard in my life
in and trust me mainstream America does
not think like you guys and you are
barking up the wrong tree have fun with
that adios Louis barking up the wrong
tree for yet another year of record
growth which I will be announcing
tomorrow yet this is a comedy show
whenever people say this I say yet a
comedy show well there's humor right
it's not totally inaccurate I mean the
funniest thing on today's show was that
voicemail so to the extent that that guy
contributed to this being a comedy show
yes this is a comedy show on today's
bonus show healthy food labels fueling
the obesity crisis Apple settles tax
fraud in Italy and a pretty interesting
story from the subway that Louis and I
have to tell you from yesterday all of
that and more david pakman.com slash
membership sign up today and remember on
friday january first 2016 everybody on
our mailing list will get notified about
a huge 2016 membership discount sign up
on our mailing list david pakman.com